tonight in the trial of Oscar Pistorius
three of his closest neighbors described
hearing a man crying the night that
reeva Steenkamp was shot it was
basically another near neighbor
demonstrated what she heard that fateful
night is it possible to make a sound
that you would resemble it good evening
from the Oscar Pistorius murder trial
here in Pretoria today we heard from the
athletes next-door neighbors including
one whose house is just 11 meters from
the bathroom where reeva Steenkamp was
shot and killed he said he was woken in
the early hours of Valentine's Day last
year by his wife after she heard a bang
another neighbor demonstrated a
high-pitched wail which she claimed was
a man screaming the defense hope that
will prove that any screaming or crying
came from mr. Pistorius and not the
sound of miss Deane campin him during a
round in another development it's being
alleged that Oscar Pistorius acted in an
intimidating manner towards a friend of
reeva Steenkamp as he left court today
expect to hear more about that later on
in the program but back to the trial and
my colleague Paul Harrison has been
following today's proceedings in the
absence of third-party witnesses to the
shooting of reeva Steenkamp last year
what and more to the point who neighbors
heard in those few minutes in the early
hours of valentine's day is crucial to
this trial state witnesses claimed they
heard the voices of both Oscar Pistorius
and reeva Steenkamp that night but some
insists they heard the cries of the
athlete alone such as pistorius's
next-door neighbor Michael in Clegg at
one Oscar is a type of a person nut
every time when he passes my house then
they see me outside
he will not really creep me by waving
his hand he will basically stop and get
out of his car to come and greet me so
we got used to that type of question
between me and him
and to share any common interest yeah no
yes we did he loved you love he loves
cars my lady and also I've got passion
for cars so basically whenever Isaac I
will pass by there and stopped by the
driveway to show musica it was on one
such occasion the Sunday before the
shooting that Oscar Pistorius was eager
to introduce reeva Steenkamp to Mister
and Langer tois so he said to me but I
would like you to meet somebody
my lady and then that's where any cold
river to come out but at that time I
didn't know that his River any
introduced her to me one thing really
that struck me about her and I don't
think I'll ever forget that moment when
she came towards me basically era is my
hand to greet her and she just opened
her arms she just came and hugged me so
to me I was you know I could see the
person that she was at that point in
time because you know when a person
brings you closer to her and basically
to close they're out the boundary of
krypton using your hand I mean it meant
something mr. Pistorius mentioned to me
because obviously when he introduced a
river to me he said please meet my
fiancee River that's why that's how she
introduced her to me and I said oh wow
and endure from there basically Riva
gave us a space between me and Oscar she
moved to us the car and I said to ask
Oscar this one is for keeps that's what
I said to him so from that moment that
mr. Oscar said you know Mike actually
I'm planning to move to Johnny's back in
much so afraid I was going to come
officially to inform you that I would be
moving out too
his back so I said to him you know what
it will be very sad to look to lose a
neighbor like you but anyway if it's for
her then I think it's worth it that's
what I said to it to him the night of
the shooting mr. and clangor toire was
woken by his wife who'd heard a loud
bang unsure if it was inside the house
or outside my concern was if it was
inside the house then I have to go and
check my daughter if she's if she's ok
so then I went out of my bedroom I went
straight to my daughter's room and then
I started checking the handle if he's
still locked because we always looked at
those when you sleep all the bedrooms so
the lock was still the door was still
locked and I could be seen that she was
still sleeping and I said to my wife no
there's nothing in the house so it
misses outside then we started hearing
you know a man that was crying very loud
the cry that we we had that those early
hours of the morning does was the person
was very desperate for help so also we
felt that probably is in danger and we
sitting out very loud it was very loud I
asked your buddy to see them man's voice
I asked you if it was a low pitch aura
or a high alert on a writer no it was a
very high pitch voice could you hear
what the person was saying it was
basically that they no please please no
so those are things that have picked up
and also continuing to cry as a lady
having gone to see what was happening
next door mr. and clangor tois told the
court what he saw as he approached Oscar
pistorius's
front door I saw Oscar he was kneeling
next to the lady who was just lying down
there was just blood all over he was
just crying at that point in time and
the gentleman that I saw mintage
increment there's one gentleman wish I
saw inside Oscars house as well
or fish Oscar was also asking him to
help me no no that's doctor step does
talk to us the gentleman that came from
that house okay madam fortune here so
basically I was just pleading with him
to help him and I could see that
obviously the situation was quite bad
and even for me I couldn't even walk
closer inside the house because yeah I
couldn't I couldn't take watching what I
saw at that point in time I mean it was
quite difficult but it received in
cross-examination prosecutor heavy Nell
pushed the witness as to why he heard
nothing
prior to someone's cries while those
living much further away say they heard
a series of loud bangs it was a bit
surprising to know that there's somebody
who's probably a hundred almost hundred
and eighty meters or other 1070 meters
away who has had what they've had is
quite interesting to hear that but I
said to him look but at a same time
again maybe at that time who were still
sleeping with didn't hear those things
that's what I said to you never any
shots
now even on the accused version on his
version he fired shots through the door
and he later broke down the door with a
cricket bat you know that's his version
of this did you hear any sounds that
could have emanated from him breaking
down the door with a cricket bat not
much not didn't hear that those songs
milady
as I said at a time for myself I had to
run around your house I'm sure if it
happened it happened when I was just
checking their house but I didn't hear
that
mr. and Clannad was wife also heard
crying a man's voice she said and was
asked to mimic the sound she heard for
the courtroom
do I help help help I had somebody say
hello you know
that's a very long family or certain
male wasn't a female it seems like a
babies paid millions wastage not long
after they yelled health noise I then
hear the song for male patients crying
the sound police and himself really hit
money and somebody needed a job is it
possible to make the sound that should
resemble it but in the Edna voice of the
Maine
yes it was finally great night and she
says they were celebrating and it was
having really voice a high key for
another short cross-examination by Harry
now meant the defense wasn't ready to
call its next witness
they hadn't arrived at court it meant a
delay followed by an apology coupled
with a little finger pointing but it is
a second problem to that I mustard race
in advance because understanding now
debated across examination of the
previous two witnesses that I can
anticipate won't take that long so again
as same problem will arise but I won't
put on record that we well within the
timeframe and if I work it out the time
frame and try and anticipate
cross-examination at times that I even
believe that we may in the defense case
by Tuesday next week
these are that confidence yeah so I'm
really sorry about the delay again that
I can anticipate is going to be caused
because I the three witnesses line that
we tried to work out yes they all have
children and we could not just bring
witnesses left right and center and I
incorrectly believed that the three
witnesses would die today
clearly that that's why range for a
certain time for the one to be picked up
but there's only one witness remaining
for the day and that's the neighbor one
of the neighbors on the other side of
that I just hope you quite correct can
you see by next week Tuesday you're
probably Mulaney of course I can't give
a guarantee but that's mine I know I've
been so wrong in my estimation the first
two days but I think it's it's fairly
accurate I think it's very accurate
we're well within the time frames okay I
hope so good to other duties we know
that's better that's why I put it on
record now thank you Mike okay yes miss
email anything to blame default not
asking enough questions that this will
be a first
that m'lady I I have no objection I
understand the predicament mr. O'Casey
coming up more dramatic screams in court
before proceedings were brought to a
rather abrupt end
welcome back another of Oscar
pistorius's next-door neighbors was
called by the defense to give her
evidence she too loudly demonstrated the
screams and cries that she heard that
night in the early hours on the 14th of
February I had a man crying and to me
the cry my lady it was a cry of pain
immediately I woke my husband up I asked
him did you hear and my lady my husband
said yes I heard but I thought I was
dreaming
then I said to my husband the crime is
real and I started panicking
I remember my lady saying to my husband
The Crying the voice it could be that
maybe one of the school the security
guard had been shot the dogs were
barking as well by then and I was
panicking we were all frightened the
crying was very loud and very close I
even remember I even thought it could be
inside the house it was very loud and
very very close and [ __ ] after crying
it was very loud
they after milady we were like sitting
on the bed before we get there when I
consulted with you I asked you if you
can just Mike
they resemble that North Circular a
crane was like and was short or
continuing the crying was continuous we
were wondering what could have happened
I even remember saying to my husband
what if it was inside the house we had
so many thoughts wondering what could
have happened my lady we couldn't move
from the bed I remember was just in a
sitting position
we couldn't switch on the light we were
just panicking panicking panicking you
see there's another 285 yes wait five I
can see another 285 we shall be true to
make easy is facing the number 205 my
lady I only had a man crying very loud
if they wasn't at that same time during
that same time a female screaming with
your father
my lady if I could have had a female
also screaming I think I could have
reflected it on my statement I only had
a man crying have you been following
this method in the media yes I was
watching my lady
so you watched it on TV as we ran the
method they remember we were subpoena to
come to court then and then we didn't
hear anything afterwards then I SM asked
him to say am i appearing on the witness
list and if so when am I going to be
called to testify and then if I remember
he responded here
by SMS to say the court doesn't intend
to call you my lady when I was breathing
to watch the television please ma'am I'm
not blaming you just want to know
bothering you so but you've been
watching it yes and you know all this
issues that came up in court about
gunshots and surface yes I can't say I
know everything yes but I've been
following I didn't hear gunshots my lady
difficulty but also the time frames to
you sir my apologies again I would ask
mr. Nell to maybe ask more questions on
Thursday to save me this embarrassment
but that and he assured me that he would
do so but the witnesses are ready for
Thursday okay now I can only estimate
that you maybe should have assisted him
with a few questions I will do simulated
well that brought today's proceedings to
a rather abrupt end although the defense
indicated that they're not only on
schedule but perhaps ahead of it and
they expect to wrap up their case by
Tuesday next week we're joining me to
discuss what happened today is Annika
Larson a South African journalists who
works for ANCA and independent
television channel and lo we'll just
nervous who is an international law
enforcement expert thank you both for
joining and confessed of all what did
you make of the witnesses today I think
they were certainly credible and that
they're professionals they were highly
qualified people and you know
well-spoken you'd call them respected
members of the community if you'd like
but they were certainly no big surprises
all are sort of drama factor today I
think that the purpose they served were
first as character witnesses and
secondly and perhaps at a far more
reduced level as there to muddy the
state's case just to muddy the waters
right exactly and you know if direct
next-door neighbors didn't hear
screaming or a rabbit wean a couple and
didn't hear gunshots then how could
people you know 70 meters down the road
have heard exactly the same thing which
we can discuss
but I think that was the main purpose
really was matting the waters and as the
character witnesses both sets of
neighbors went out of the way to say how
friendly Oscar Pistorius was how he went
to both their homes to try and welcome
them when they came to the estate what
did you make of their evidence well I
tried to decide whether this was
actually witnesses or character
witnesses busy testifying I think
there's a big emphasis by the defense to
put a to create an atmosphere of who
Oscar Pistorius really is that he's a
nice person and that he was really hurt
by what he did etcetera etcetera
I didn't think the last witnesses really
contributed much towards anybody's case
well I thought they first of all and I'm
sure the dent defense will argue this
that they argued fairly successfully
that they did not hear a woman screaming
or around exactly I mean that there was
no mention of that at all in fact they
were adamant that what they heard was a
very high-pitched man screaming and they
were very they were very adamant about
that and clear about it you could see
they'd spent some time going over their
statements and Harry Nell in
cross-examination did ask them are you
you didn't hear a woman and and they
said no it was a man's voice we don't
seem to have a huge number of expert
witnesses we all expected the ballistics
expert mr. Vollmer ons to testify
yesterday and when he didn't appear we
definitely were certain that he was
going to appear today and well the rest
is history I can only speculate why is
not in court what is your speculation
well it has a couple of different
they're difficult questions to answer
and the thing about an expert is that an
expert should under all circumstances
give evidence about his findings and not
to suit the version of his client and
once it seems once it seems that an
expert was maybe stepping over the line
between objectivity and the clients
story that person loses credibility and
may
not be used again so an expert and I
would say at the moment Tong's Vollmer
ants can't be accused of that because we
haven't heard from it we haven't heard
of him but we haven't heard from him yet
but he still has difficult questions to
answer and one has to be careful what
you say in the box especially in the
circumstances like these where it's
viewed internationally you have to be
very careful I always say when I'm
called into a court I'm not 99% sure my
case I'm a hundred percent sure of my
case about the defense not having their
witnesses ready
should they be blamed for that should
they be thanks for that I think they
should be criticized for that they're
more than ample time to line up the
witnesses the state said their witnesses
already and I'm quite sure that if the
state didn't bring a witness in time
they would have been criticized very
very very directly and immediately so I
can't understand why they witnesses on
all waiting outside court well thank you
very much Loeb with us nervous and Anika
Larson for joining us there was much
controversy and debate over whether
Oscar Pistorius had spoken to some of
reeva Steenkamp friends after the court
had adjourned today and exactly what
he'd said if he indeed had spoken to
them though this statement was issued by
the Myers family lawyer he said my
client Kim Myers was approached by Oscar
Pistorius in court today and in a very
sinister tone was asked how can you
sleep at night my client views this
unwelcome approach as extremely
disturbing and I've been in
communication with the National
prosecuting authorities as well as the
investigating officer all other parties
have been informed well we approached
the National Prosecuting Authority and
they said their hands were tied and
they're told the lawyer in Leavitt that
they they wouldn't be taking it any
further unless the Myers family chose to
take it further the Myers family as
you'll remember are very close friends
of reeva Steenkamp in fact that was the
house where she had been living for some
time I along with a number of other
reporters approached Oscar Pistorius
about it to see what he had to say about
it and the athlete flatly denied talking
at all to any member of the Myers family
what he described as weeks he said that
he often passed them on his way in and
out of the courtroom and he felt that
they were avoiding eye contact with him
so a complete denial from Oscar
Pistorius well there's no court tomorrow
because of the South African general
election but please do join us again on
Thursday for the rolling coverage of the
Oscar Pistorius murder trial and of
course our catch-up program every night
at 9:30 thanks for watching